introduce my panelists first of all
Elaine Elaine weary co-founder of me bow
me bow provides web-based instant
communication with all the major I am
network services Elaine tells me that
they are serving about 60 million
messages a day they're backed by Sequoia
dfj and angel investors including Marc
Andreessen founder of Netscape she used
to work at synaptics as the manager of
usability she was here majoring in
symbolic systems at Stanford and she
plays violin and grew up on a goat farm
I love I love that I love that right
next to me is Jeff Jordan Jeff the
fellow GSB R of mine although you were
in were you in the illustrious class of
okay never mind
Jeff was part of the senior team of eBay
from 1999 until just recently his last
role there was as president of PayPal in
Ojai PayPal processed over 27 billion in
total payment volume before that he was
SVP and GM of eBay North America where
he had responsibility for eBay comm eBay
Motors half.com eBay Canada and he also
led a Bayes acquisition of PayPal prior
to eBay he was CFO of Hollywood
entertainment president and real calm
spent eight years at the Walt Disney
Company managing strategic planning for
consumer products and served as the CFO
of Disney stores worldwide I bet your
kids like that at the time yeah that
would be pretty cool he's on the boards
of pure digital and meta web and BA from
Amherst MBA from here Chad Hurley
CEO of YouTube I'm sure you guys
probably know that which he co-founded
in February of oh five YouTube is one of
the most highly trafficked websites
serving billions of videos worldwide as
CEO in fact I have to tell them funny
story which is when I was speaking to
your PR folks and they asked me if there
would be any press here I said well I
don't think so but you guys should know
that within seconds anything you say
might be posted and available for
millions of viewers
dangerous that's right that's right
that's why oh that's why we make them
turn off their phones now we get it
as CEO Chad oversees business
development marketing and operations for
the company
he created the clean interface that
YouTube is known for and his vision is
to keep the process of watching and
sharing videos effortless for everyone
prior to YouTube Chad was the first UI
designer PayPal where he played a
fundamental role in the early
development of the payment service he
also consulted to the producers of the
hit movie thank you for smoking and I
definitely want to know about that
although it's not in my question so
somebody else asked about that he has a
BA in fine art go non tech majors from
Indiana University of Pennsylvania
Mark Zuckerberg mark is the founder and
CEO of Facebook probably don't need to
tell you that either in that role he
sets overall direction and product
strategy for the company Facebook has
over 16.25 million registered users more
than half of whom come back every single
day they're the seventh most visited
site in the US and the largest photo
sharing site in the world
and their users upload six million
photos a day and those are just a few of
the statistics I got from mark
they're so remarkable that I could go on
and on about them but those are just a
few
he created Facebook while a Harvard
undergrad and dropped out joining the
great ranks of other dropouts like Bill
Gates in February of 2004 he attended
Harvard for two years before and he also
was a psychology major so yet not
another not technical were you oh okay
they told me you were a psych major so
Oh
I'll tell you later he believes free
flow of information is one of his models
which he just proved he still likes
Green Day which is worries me because I
like Green Day and I thought I was a
cool mom for liking Green Day and I
guess I must be uncool and his favorite
quote is never run out of ammo so that's
my facebook profile okay that's really
so anyway I'm gonna I'm gonna start off
in the ground rules here or I've got
some questions I kind of if nobody pipes
up I pick somebody you're all free to
chime in and the more the merrier so my
first one is hey there there been other
video sharing sites there are other
payment sites there were other college
related community related sites
why did you succeed dramatically when
the others didn't both eBay and PayPal
participated in massive existing
industries ones retail ones financial
services but brought a highly disruptive
approach to those industries PayPal
frankly enables people to do something
they couldn't do online which is anyone
can send money to anyone and it's filled
a huge need so I think you know the
voracious adoption of it I think it's a
hundred forty hundred fifty million
users now is around the need that was
fulfilled that it wasn't at all
fulfilled by the current financial
service was there one single thing that
you got right that the other people
didn't get something that made it
frictionless something too attached you
to growth engine then what the I mean to
be truth in advertising guys like Chad
and David God did write because they did
it before we bought them I think the
thing they did best of all was leverage
the eBay community with incredibly
intelligent and great great usability as
well as a $5 bounty and the entire
community adopted it rapidly and the
other thing they did that was fairly
brilliant max leptin had a lot of hands
the fraud one point the fraud was higher
than as high as the payment by him going
through it and now it's measured in
basis points and so they couple key
things that the leverage but without
that you've a network paypal probably
would have existed yeah so yeah it's
starting YouTube we did you know drawn a
lot of our experience from PayPal we saw
the power of just simplifying a problem
for people so PayPal and PayPal case
that was payments then we saw an
opportunity in the video space to
simplify that and make it easy for
everyone to put a video online and then
you know with PayPal we had payment
buttons that would allow people to they
could put these buttons on their
auctions and people could pay directly
and we created a video embed on YouTube
where people could post them on myspace
profiles on websites on blogs and this
really attributed to a lot of our viral
growth it was basically free marketing
for us that we weren't paying for the
only thing that we did have to pay for
was bandwidth and you know in the case
with the the fraud that we were able to
control PayPal we were able to build a
video architecture that was very
efficient very consistent so we always
delivered a good service to our users I
like to focus on is efficiency and
people need to get information about the
people around them and stay connected
with people and I think that one thing
that all these services have in common
when I was talking about information
flow is talking about Facebook but all
of them have in common is that they're
just more efficient ways of doing things
that were always possible to do so I
mean you could transfer money before but
now you could do it online okay you
could share a video before but now you
can post it and asynchronously millions
of people can view it same thing on
Facebook you can update your Facebook
profile and leave it there for a very
long time and then someone random can
come and get information about it it's
introducing so and I think that because
we're allowing things to be done more
efficiently than they were able to be
done before people just naturally
gravitate towards those things so I mean
and we even see that now I mean the
growth of these services is continuing I
mean I know that Facebook is doubling
every five or six months now so that's
still huge I'm sure YouTube is growing
at a huge rate - mm-hmm
yeah which is another thing you know we
VCS talk about this all the time because
when we miss good ones like all the ones
represented here
and we talk about what did they do right
that you know those ones we funded
didn't do right and I think one thing
you guys all did well really well is
figured out that scaling seamlessly was
really important or as seamlessly as you
could and I was thinking about this in
the context of remember when eBay had
the outage that lasted for what five six
hours and I remember thinking two things
one is you couldn't buy that much
publicity about how important eBay was
by the stories about how important the
fact that it was down was and then I
thought you guys better not have that
ever happen again or you're screwed
because you know I mean so many people
complained about losing revenue and all
that so scaling I mean Alain if you want
to start you must be dealing with it now
and you're a tiny little startup I know
you got all those bucks from Sequoia and
dfj but you know they don't want you to
spend them yeah scaling has definitely
been a number one barrier barrier to
entry I'm just scaling and Ajax I am app
is absolutely non-trivial that was one
of the first things we had to tackle we
had to do on the back ends and he's
actually here and so she can use her
hand but on the back ends and he was
responsible for getting the
infrastructure set up and doing things
that nobody had ever done before and on
the front end we were one of the first
people that kind of introduced long
polling before the term comment had even
been had really a arisen so if you
looked at the blogs a year before meepo
launch people had said to what we're
doing with absolutely impossible so we
were we were sandy and I are just people
who really like challenges so we were up
to being able to solve that but that has
absolutely been that in the user
community have absolutely been our two
biggest things for barrier to entry
today you guys had any scaling glitches
horror stories no well there's one I
mean there's a guy sitting right there
who built Facebook photos and I mean we
found we take a very iterative approach
to developing things so we'll first
throw stuff out just like okay like the
original site was thrown together in
about two weeks and then as time goes on
we just iterate on the the architecture
and scale it from there Facebook photos
when we first launched
I guess whatever the architecture was it
lasted for about a month and then you
know the site was a little bit slow for
a couple of weeks until they completely
redid that and now it's like handles I
think we're near nearly a billion photos
it's like more than six million uploaded
every day I don't know I mean we just
have also scaled up to a lot of traffic
at this point we're doing over a billion
page views a day so it's it's just a lot
and I mean if you think about some of
the massive architectures that people
have on the internet I mean Google runs
hundreds of thousands of servers and
ours is still measured in the
single-digit thousands mm-hmm so scaling
yeah well clearly I mean part of scaling
is throwing hardware and throwing cycles
at the problem and knowing when to do it
but part of it is the constant
redesigning you guys must do with your
with your architecture I mean I know
people think of a lot of what you do as
community being your product but I think
underlying that is is a hell of a lot of
software that underlies your product so
you've got it you must have to manage
that and you must have to evolve it
really quickly to stay up with with what
your users want and also to keep you
ahead of there's always competition
right even if you're ahead of the
competition there's other folks doing
stuff how do you manage that process
well you know kind of touching on and
how we continue to grow it's yes you
want solid architecture and we've been
have been able to build that early on so
we've been able to scale down any you
know kind of a slowdown but another
thing you really have to be aware of is
how the community is using the product
not making any assumptions and to really
listen to the users during the process
so you know to us the community is very
important and you know the features that
we had on day one we had ideas that a
lot of people would use it to post
videos on eBay to describe their their
products or what they're selling and and
we just saw our users really using it as
a way to communicate and to watch videos
and be entertained so over time we do we
just adjusted the UI and I think that
that you know by itself has allowed us
to continue to grow and create a brand
that people would use and Elaine I mean
you're riding on a bunch of other
people's architectures right you're
knitting it all together so how do you
how do you keep that competitive I think
it's just a methodology that we try
something and if it doesn't work then we
try and either improve it or we look to
something else
and we're definitely not trying to
reinvent the wheel sandy and I were
working together with Seth two years
prior to me beau and during that time we
created two products that were almost
ready to friends and family really
friends and family launched and during
that entire process we always had kind
of an engineering instinct and we wanted
to reinvent everything we wanted to
rewrite everything and over those two
years we became much more disciplined
about looking to what the community has
done I mean the two of us cannot even
start touching all the things that are
in the open-source community today so we
just want to be able to build upon that
and also in turn eventually be able to
get back to that community as well so so
I have a couple kids which is how I
learn about what young people are doing
on the Internet I just watch what they
do and I knew I'd gotten to my daughter
as a venture capitalist when one day she
was sitting there and she was playing on
neopets and she said mom I just I'm not
getting this and I said are you having
trouble you know creating you know
character what and she goes no I I don't
get the business model and she was like
11 I was so psyched I'm like man I'm set
my retirements gonna be paid for so so I
think you know one of the interesting
things is you know when I first got into
venture capital it was all about
eyeballs and then eyeballs didn't turn
out to be such a good thing to measure
and the ad market went up the ad market
went down and and really all three of
you are not monetizing use of your
products per se so how do you how do you
monetize it I mean what are is it is it
is it all ad is it what where is it
going and where do you think it's gonna
go in the future
any one of you well we want to keep our
service free and we've we've always felt
that way and we always knew early on
that it would be an advertising model
for us we you know and the the space
that we're dealing with we are creating
a video site and entertainment
destination where people will be
engaging and you'll be able to have
opportunity to do brand or brand
advertising which gets a higher CPM
online so but we didn't want that to
slow down our growth initially so we did
keep a lot of advertising off of the
site and I think there's better
opportunities to innovate in this space
and we're gonna be testing you know many
different ways to have people engage
with advertisements because we don't
want it to be distracting to their
experience so you know of all the
companies that we could have been
acquired by Google's been
perfect fit for us because they do that
on a daily basis they present text ads
that are relevant to your searches and
we're going to be incorporating that
technology into our video experience and
did I did I read that you're gonna start
sharing the revenue with the creators
yeah how are you gonna how you gonna do
that well it would be a simple revenue
share how people earn you know money on
Adsense we'll be incorporating ways for
people to get revenue through ads they
show on their videos what are you saying
Facebook is also a free service and we
found the need to scale up ad revenue as
we've scaled up the company right now we
just do a lot of traditional advertising
stuff so I mean we have a deal with
Microsoft where they sell a bunch of
advertising for us we sell a lot for
ourselves and our own products like like
newsfeed and we have our own self
service products things like Flyers that
some of you guys might be aware I think
eventually where this goes is that the
advertising needs to match what people
are doing on the site so it's not one
type of advertising that's gonna fit
every single type of site I mean the
revenue share that I think you're doing
on YouTube is seems like a really clever
thing to do and when Google's
advertising was certainly unique when it
came along and I mean originally they
did that just because I mean from
talking to those guys because they
didn't want to clutter up the page and
they kind of acknowledged early on like
okay maybe text ads aren't even as
valuable as banner ads but it turns out
that that was not correct but but I mean
they did that because they kind of fit
the product that they had and we're kind
of working on a lot of stuff like that
and I think that that's sort of where
this goes Elaine you're the relative
newbie here I mean you've started your
company a whole two years after these
guys and I'm sure the world has changed
dramatically in those two years since a
lot of folks are probably gonna be
starting companies here in the next year
or two any anything that you think has
changed from the time that these guys
got started to when you got started I
think first off the startup
infrastructure just technology is
cheaper so it's a lot easier to get
things off of the ground which is
fantastic I think the flip side of that
is there a lot more people who are doing
startups today and a lot more people who
are clamoring for bloggers and users
attention
I think as a as a result of that I think
that people are there's still the
entrepreneurial spirit and that's
absolutely fantastic but I think that
kind of there's this Web 2.0 space and
then some people still have kind of web
1.0 expectations of of massive massive
returns I think that probably needs to
be tempered a little bit on the other
side I think that users have also
evolved and so maybe to five years ago
people whenever you want whenever you
had a startup you wanted it to look like
Microsoft you wanted it to look very
slick you wanted it to look very
professional and I think today what
people when people go to sites they're
looking for something that's very
different they're looking for a
transparency they expect you to have a
blog they expect you to have a community
and I think that it's through that that
you're that you have to be able to gain
your users trust a little bit
differently than you did two to five
years ago Jeff got a question for you
a couple years ago I heard the CEO of
Nielson speak and I was astounded by
what she said she said that the top
rated US television show today I can't
remember if it was American Idol or 24
but I think it was one of those has a
smaller viewership than the 20th
highest-rated television show from 20
years ago which I thought was quite
remarkable and and and one of our
portfolio the cast portfolio company is
actually the one that Chris Anderson was
was interviewing the CEO and he came up
with the longtail concept because we
were saying that you know our our whole
our whole database gets played quite a
lot more than one would think one would
think it's all the top tracks but really
the spread is quite broad do you think
that the mass market is dead and and if
so what are the implications on the kind
of stuff you've been doing already or
the kind of stuff you might be new and
next they chris is a friend so the folks
who've been exposed to longtail concept
that a lot of the growth on the net is
coming from not the core product that's
extensively distributed everywhere but
things are way down the curve eBay is a
long-tailed company you know if you look
at a traditional product life cycle you
know early on it explodes into retail
and then it goes you know it goes into
overstock remainder
secondary use and used eBay is all the
things that don't sell them them all so
the whole concept has been predicated on
and trying to create efficient
distribution where there was an
efficient distribution before and in the
middle of the product lifecycle curve
everything sold in the mall is
unbelievably efficient cutthroat has low
returns on capital so you know eBay's
long tail Amazon's long tail
user-generated content you know is all
long tail I think it's what the net does
particularly well that it because it's
access to information and you know the
ability to search and find what's
important to people it tastes is
increasingly taste and availability it's
because li not dictated by a company
that's making editorial or fashion
choices is dictated by the consumer who
can pull that based on the net ability
to pull information and pull them and to
extent have it be supplied extensively
and find the only one of those in the
world so I think the net why the long
tail worked on the net is because it
doesn't work in the real world and then
that enables it so I think a lot of the
best and most successful concepts are
taking advantage of this in their
relative industry it's just the
informational power and the searching
power of the net what seems like all you
guys are gonna have to concentrate on
the places where the most volume is
right I mean is there because you go to
55 60 percent of all retail is done of
first extensively distributed first you
know new and retail goods and eBay
essentially doesn't play there exception
in what I'm thinking about which is if
you're a brand owner and you're gonna
come and buy advertising for example
you're gonna want to buy it on the on
the thing that's viewed thousands
hundred thousand times not that you know
my daughter uploaded a picture of her
firing a potato cannon in our backyard
and and I went on and looked and there
had actually been 32 people who viewed
it and I'm thinking they need a life
because I mean how did 32 people even
find the picture version of your potato
cannon
as you start to monetize this and
revenue share is there something you're
gonna do to make sure that there is
interesting content or is there some
benefit or some difference you're gonna
have for the the top-performing assets
or is it just all smooth scale or just
yeah we're just gonna allow everyone to
participate that's what has set us apart
and that then other video sites in the
past where they were making the
editorial decisions up front they were
deciding what was entertaining for their
community and we don't have that we
allow the audience to decide what's
entertaining and that will you know in
turn rise to the top for more people to
view so you know the buyer side the ad
buyer side are they looking for a
particular amount of runs on a
particular video are they looking to
exclude some forms of content and I
think I have to build that flexibility
into the system how they want to target
an individual you have that in you know
any service I think so we're gonna be
building that into our system but in
terms of talking about it you know
diversification if distribution I think
you're talking about networks and the
content that they bring or studios or
labels it's it's just what's happening
because people are spending more time in
different places it's a TV ratings are
going to go down because you have DVDs
you have more movies you have
pay-per-view you have the internet so
they just need to reach out just like
advertisers reach out it to more places
to reach their audience yeah just back
to the mass market whether it's dead I
don't know just from a social
perspective I whenever I'm talking with
all of my friends or just people in
light my clothes peer circle we've all
seen the same kind of the same I don't
know star wars kid videos we've all seen
the same like Ok Go videos like just
from like looking around everybody
always seems to be consuming the same
things we also may be paying attention
to the same blogs to the same kind of
news sources and I think that kind of I
think that that's why you've seen so
much attention being placed on feeds and
aggregators recently is because
everybody seems to be consuming I go to
my computer I sit down and for 20 after
20 minutes I feel like I've consumed
everything there is on the Internet
during that time and I know that's not
the case but I don't think anybody's
really been able to solve that problem
of looking for kind of niche things or
when you don't have a targeted search
how do you find things that are just
interesting I'm just laughing because my
kid said to me a couple weeks ago I told
me you know I never I never prevent you
guys from watching TV cuz honestly when
I was a kid I watched a ton of TV and I
turned out okay so you know you guys can
watch as much TV as you want and my
little one I'm not gonna choose eight at
the time she said to me mom you know
honestly when you were a kid the world
only knew so much so pretty much by
three o'clock they were done telling you
everything and now the world knows so
much more that they can keep us busy all
day at school and we're still not done
so I I don't you know I think it is
interesting I mean I share that I get
over whelm init's a newsfeed and I just
can't read anymore because I'm dead but
the flip side of that is I always feel
like there's more you know you get such
depth out of any topic you want to go
into you can just find an infinite
amount of material on it which is which
is tough so so so speaking about that I
mean you guys all all of all of us live
in the sort of primordial soup of the
next startup and the current hot trend
and who got funded and who got bought
out and how much happened for each of
you love to hear what you think the
smartest one is you know what's your
favorite thing to use or your favorite
side or your favorite company the one
you really admire for what they're doing
and the flipside of that is the one
you'd run screaming from the building if
if they made you invest I mean what's
your and you know you don't have to
answer this but you know is there a
trend that you think is just being way
over hyped is there you know your
turn-ons your turn-offs I mean you know
which which are the ones Jeff well I'm
unemployed so anything looks good now
I'll come back let's do best oh it's
gonna be big
no I think any service that helps people
find information you know like a
Technorati helping people sift through
you know amounts of blog data that's out
there anything is a good investment I'm
a sucker for the sites that have put in
I don't know how to put this have put
into meThe hooks so that the user that
the user community can just own the site
and so I think examples of that are like
eBay eBay it just allows people to
customize customize their site to own it
I think another example of that is
Craigslist
I think another example of that is of
course Facebook and MySpace but those
are the things that really get me
excited mm-hmm I think that Wikipedia is
by far the coolest thing I think there
are like the whole trend with all these
things is that instead of just having
one source where information is pumped
at you you have a lot of different
sources that come together to produce
the solution or the answer or the
article if you're on Wikipedia or the
answer to the question what's going on
around you with all my friends if you're
on Facebook or what are interesting
videos if you're on YouTube I mean in a
lot of ways a lot of these services do
the same thing but it's I think it's
because of the amount of liquidity and
the number of people using these
services and the ease of information
flow that that can be possible mm-hmm I
think Wikipedia is really cool I do
think it's gonna be interesting to watch
how it evolves from a user etiquette
perspective I mean I I went on once and
and and I found something and I found
that I had an entry I didn't know I had
an entry and I didn't like something in
it so I edited it out and then I I told
one of my partners Brad Feld who runs
this blog that's pretty popular and he
said you're not supposed to touch your
own entry I said well how am I supposed
to know that you know and I you know
he's like you're gonna get in trouble
you're gonna get kicked out for doing
this and nothing ever happened
so I'm I think I might go and actually
improve it so so anyway the flipside the
one anybody willing to admit ones where
they just scratch their head and say
what are people thinking I mean there
are a lot of companies that still try to
do things the old way and think that
that's the most efficient way so I mean
I think that a lot of what maybe
traditional media companies are doing on
the Internet is backwards I mean
especially when you know you get a room
full of people who run newspaper
companies asking you know like shaddid
and myself you know how they should
change their company to work with the
web it's kind of like well you just
don't have the right to foundation and
first of all you're not a technology
company second this is it about
information being pumped from one source
this is about you know a lot of
different sources I don't think those
are gonna do very well me too investing
that goes on behind winners and I in the
payment space I'm not to say none of
them will get traction but you just read
every week there's another payment
concept coming in it's mobile it's
something that's that's trying to do a
slight tweak because that had been
successful the video sites there are a
few of them I told ya and you know that
the it's it's feeling in the valley a
little frothy mm ish why where the
valuations are extraordinary the early
evaluations are extraordinary yeah it's
more you know companies are so started
with kind of original ideas yeah why
also think it's just it's one of my pet
peeves as a venture capitalist is when
you get pitched a lot of things that
entrepreneurs believe that because it
doesn't exist today it's never going to
exist and they really don't anticipate
that companies are going to be doing
those things you know that you know I
remember looking at one that was a video
you know Han he'll
video player like two years ago and I
said you know I bet apples gonna do
something in this space I mean it's not
hard to figure out where a lot of these
companies are going and I've just been
surprised that that you know I there I
kind of say there are two kinds of
entrepreneurs there's the eternally
optimistic who never does any due
diligence on what else might be out
there right they just get an idea and
they go and and it's always so awkward
you're sitting in a meeting with them
and they're telling you their idea and
you know have you ever seen X Y Z comma
go how you'd like to type it up and it's
exactly what they're doing it's already
there and they just they don't want to
see it and then the other ones are the
totally paranoid who are constantly
coming you know and it's sort of in some
ways is better to be paranoid than
optimistic maybe you got to be both but
it there is a lot of me too going on so
you know I'm sure there's a lot of
budding entrepreneurs in the audience
and so before I turn it over I want to
ask a couple you know more the human
side of what y'all are doing so the
first one is is just what tools do you
guys do to do your job I mean what do
you what do you what are you most
relying on yourself to do your job
that's my kid no it's actually it's
really funny as your kids kids consume
differently my kid said wake up in the
morning my son Sprint's to YouTube and
just starts and you know he gone to
Saturday morning if you let him he will
spend six hours and it's just what I
used to do another TV he does it's so
fun to watch my kid is on world of
warcraft about 25 hours a week scape
yeah Guild Wars yeah
do any of you guys use email or is that
just what old people do it's hard yeah
really
stay up on it yeah the amount of email
that you use it's it's better to receive
an instant message you know or you have
to receive a call just yourself oh yeah
anything else any other tools you like
no Excel anymore right probably one of
the most important things is just
surrounding like to do your job is just
rounding yourself with really good
people and so I think hiring practices
are far underrated just make sure you
know what you're gonna ask have your
good good questions all figured out from
the get-go
the technologies we all have that why
are you all the time you have some
unintended consequences that just when
you're running a global business and
with lots of people something's always
going wrong at some renown on the clock
so a good friend of mine who worked at
one of your new company's main
competitors used to keep his blackberry
under his pillow and you know the thing
was is you know so it's 3:00 in the
morning and it's buzzing away you're
like why are you doing that yourself but
you're all expected to always be on you
know the five hundred six hundred emails
and hey the the cellphones multiple cell
phones rings it's just it's harder to
get work when I worked it out by said
the Sun never sets on a problem that I
seem to need solved right cuz you get up
and you'd have all your email from you
know other parts of the world so it is
really hard and the other thing I've
noticed even personally I've noticed
that last night I noticed my family
we're all sitting around and we're
sitting in a really small room and
everybody's got a laptop on wireless and
while sitting there talking but
everybody's doing you know and that's
kind of how our every evening is span is
everybody's got their own device and
they're kind of you know partial
constant partial attention I think is
what it's called Network we kind of
think about the massive population of
people using these services as a tool
for producing more information so I mean
take the photos example we have this
thing that I think is pretty cool where
you can tag other people in photos it's
not super original except for the fact
that then I can go to someone's profile
and see photos of them so there's this
whether they took the photo or not so
there's this effect where ninety percent
or so of people on the site have photos
taken of them whereas less than half of
people have ever uploaded a photo so I
mean you have all these people kind of
collaborating and creating this
information store actually I have this
story that I think is pretty funny that
I kind of described as the perfect
social story when I was making Facebook
during my fall semester of sophomore
year in college I was I was doing it
dude was supposed to be studying for
finals and um there's this class of Rome
of Augustus it was an art history class
that I
that I hadn't really gotten to all term
because as art history and computer
science major and said I'll be
elaborating on me and for the spinal
exam we we had to learn the historical
significance of about five hundred
images from this period so I spent the
time that I should have been studying
for the exam writing face book so I was
screwed so about a day or two before the
exam I went to the course website
downloaded all the photos that we needed
to learn the meaning of for this exam
made a new website where it consisted of
a page for each of these photos each
page had the photo a box underneath to
write comments I sent an email out to
the class list saying hey guys I built a
study tool and everyone went and filled
in all the information for each of these
photos so I got in that class but I mean
I think that's really not that different
than anything that anyone else here is
doing I think that that's really similar
to what Wikipedia is doing you know it's
really similar to the approach that
Facebook takes both in the photos
example that I used and just overall for
helping people know what's going on
around them you know we don't have a
single source to tell people what's
going on around them we have 16 million
people each updating a little bit of
information about themselves a person
specifies what their network is and now
they can log in and quickly get a sense
of what's going on around them so that's
our tool yeah it's pretty cool actually
and I think there are some really
interesting things we're gonna see over
time like that the ecaps network this
jukebox Network you know we don't
monetize this yet but one things that
has occurred to us is on any given
Saturday night we know what's playing in
10,000 bars across America most of which
are skewed towards the 22 to 25 year old
and it's pretty interesting to see what
music pops up what you know what gets
played and and the labels we're just
starting to talk with the labels about
how do you monetize that how are we
gonna help you guys how we're gonna help
you promote what are you going to learn
from the data that we're
collecting and so you know that's
obviously collateral benefit from the
business you know one of the businesses
that that company is in which is which
is pretty cool
entrepreneurship it's it's got its it
was the best of times it was the worst
of times
there's some great moments there are
some bad moments any particularly great
moments any particularly bad moments
when you thought I love this this is the
best thing I've ever done when was that
moment where you said I'm this close to
quitting and you didn't quit I know
that's a that's a big open-ended
question but I think again there's a lot
of folks in in the room here who are
probably going to go off and and throw
their MBAs or whatever other degrees
they're getting away and start their own
companies good idea by the school I
started my company right out of business
school and but it was so long ago I was
one of only like two students who did
that and and my parents said to me why
are you wasting that degree like someday
it'll be valuable really I'm still
waiting for that no I'm kidding highly
valuable keep sending those checks to
the to the office but anyway um good
moment bad moment why are you doing this
why it keeps why you keep going it's
just you know seeing the world respond
to what you've created I mean you know
we've been fortunate to be a PayPal to
create YouTube and just to see you know
our company or our idea can affect how
people around the world is for us that
that was that you know one of the
biggest you know thrills for us and then
being acquired by by eBay for 1.65
billion dollars you've actually you've
been acquired twice now is this your
pattern for you or I don't know I mean
at PayPal we actually had the chance to
go public first so yeah it was yeah
that's very cool
I mean it's also interesting I I know I
think about a lot what's happening right
now is you guys really are changing the
world a lot I mean all you guys when you
think about what you're able to
accomplish the people you put in
business when you think about some of
the political implications of some of
the things that have happened on your
site it's
incredible and I think again we're just
at the beginning of that for me that's
one of the exciting things is to watch
how quickly some things evolved because
of all the work that's happening bad
moments bad moments nobody has any bad
moments I said I sent to my partners I
said what questions would you like to
ask my panel and they said ask them how
many times they've wanted to Club their
venture capitalists over the head well
we didn't have a chance to get to that
point we were 18 months and and course
was good so yeah no one will know what
you say in this room no I actually don't
have that bad stories I mean I think
that at Facebook we've been really
selective about who we've led into the
company both in terms of people working
at the company and in investors our
first investor was Peter Thiel who was
the founder of PayPal and the reason why
I wanted to work with him instead of
just a venture capitalist is because
when I first came out to the valley I
was 19 years old and I was very scared
of venture capitalists and rightly so I
don't know Jim briars not that serious
um but but I mean I heard a lot of
stories about you know okay like
basically like what venture capitalist
news they invest in your company and
then they kick you out all right sweet
yeah that sounds good but but I figured
Peter Thiel had been through this whole
process I mean he'd both taken a company
public and then sold it he scaled up a
company gone through a lot of different
stuff so I figured that he's more of an
entrepreneur that entrepreneur than
anything else and I mean that's kind of
how we chose him as our first investor
and then there's time scale time went on
added briar she's good too yeah yeah so
question for you and and I this will be
my last question then I'll open it up to
you guys you moved here you started it
somewhere else and you decide to come
here and I'm I'm gonna speak on a panel
on Friday about the Silicon Valley and
the economic situation here and you know
is it over is it good why'd you come
here what made you come here
originally I just planned on being out
here for the summer after my sophomore
year having my roommate Dustin and I he
was my co-founder we started the site
when like in the middle of the school
year and we were taking pretty hard
classes and you know the site was
growing pretty quickly and we figured
you know it was really hard to both to
run the site and take these classes so
at the end of the summer we just kind of
decided all right we'll stay out here
for a semester Harvard does the school
thing where they will let you stop out
basically like Stanford for as long as
you want and then we just took it
semester by semester for a while so I
mean fall semester or like all right
we'll stay then thanks for scaling
pretty well spring semester we decided
okay things they're still doubling had a
good clip like just seems good and we
took money from Excel now we're here
yeah actually right yeah we are I mean
we have two offices in downtown Palo
Alto now getting a third soon building
an urban campus it's pretty good you're
right you're right by the bead shop
right
I've seen your so yeah that's pretty
cool so Elaine is it hard to hire
against all these mega companies in the
valley are you hiring outside the valley
how are you building your team
absolutely we've we've hired one of our
when we're back envelop Erza's for North
Carolina or graphic designer is from
Italy one of our front-end developers is
from is from the UK so we're absolutely
open to hiring anybody from anywhere and
also plug jobs me Bo comm if anybody is
interested I think that I think that one
of the things we've learned just
recently is just making sure that
whenever you are you do have higher
higher bars it's just making sure that
you appeal to kind of like the the
techie and the love of challenges and so
one of the things we've done is we
started posting all sorts of little
puzzlers on our job site and that's been
really helpful is it still the place to
be her you packing up and moving in in
terms of the robustness of ideas and and
I think the capital the entrepreneurs I
mean it's still place to be it's
interesting you talk to VCS outside of
the area and I starting to one who's got
this wildly successful track record and
goes I'm just you know the pawns are a
lot smaller but there's no one else here
and so it's a East Coast guy and so I do
think still the aggregation of the
vibrancy is here you know the number of
successful companies that relocate here
is you know testament to that makes it
Ruta Lee hard to hire and retain people
yeah it sure does sure does well I'd
love to open it up to questions
yeah pretty interesting I've talked to
Peter about this a bit but in a lot of
ways PayPal was scaling up and it was
gonna be sort of the fifth big internet
company and you know the other four kept
going I mean I'm kind of thinking of
Google Yahoo eBay and Amazon and then
PayPal got acquired and sort of sent out
everyone into the world right we're not
sending out everyone into the world so I
mean I hopefully they're gonna keep on
building cool stuff at Facebook and not
become alums and go build their own cool
things but I mean but there are some
people who have left in their successful
I mean for example Steve Chen your
co-founder worked at Facebook and from
what I could tell was probably thinking
about YouTube while he was there but
that's okay that's okay
no I mean that's fine but I mean but I
figured those irrelevant answer to your
question you know as a side point have
you noticed that like there's more
connections just among the members of
this this panel then there are like your
average daytime soap so which is why I
know what you guys all do during the day
so it is interesting it's like never
piss anybody off because well you can
see why so interesting to keep all those
connections open questions yeah
this is just making it open allowing
people to grab payment buttons allowing
people to grab in beds allowing the
communities to spread the bite
word-of-mouth what you're doing your
brand so you know and then beds we had
little watermarks we have little
watermarks for YouTube so we wanted to
expose that to people just by giving
them a free service and it you know in
turn they were there spreading the word
we slowed down growth quite a bit I mean
when we were in college we had no money
so we literally rented a server for $85
a month and we put ads up against that
because we didn't want to lose $85 so I
mean as we made money off of that
we just started renting more servers and
launching more schools and early on it
was just available at Harvard and
everyone at Harvard was using it within
a couple of weeks then we started
getting emails from people at other
schools asking for us to launch the
service there and you know Dustin and I
didn't know if we wanted to spend our
time working on this we want to make
sure that this was a really good thing
before we invested a lot of time in it
so we launched it first at three schools
that already had online communities
which were Columbia Yale and Stanford
and when it kind of went through those
really quickly as well then we were like
all right this is probably gonna scale
so then we started launching it at a
bunch of other places
um I mean from there it's just been
mostly viral and word-of-mouth yeah and
we and we didn't have any expectations
either we just we thought this would be
a cool project to work on and we had an
interest and we still an opportunity to
potentially help people with video so we
just kind of rolled it out there on some
servers where it's hosting and just kind
of saw how people are reacting to it and
you know over a few months of just gonna
working on it on our own we we saw an
opportunity but you know we weren't
necessarily setting out to create you
know a large company so and I mean
increasingly if you look at all the ADIZ
companies and the big four whatever we
call them every one of those just took
off from inception just we go wildly
quickly Skype widely quickly and given
you can now start a company you know
your infrastructure in your cost can be
a lot lower
you know this whole concept of getting
something out you often prevent your
round and you know if it fits a need
then that is it a stage of development
where people to seem to be finding it
you know and the astonishing you know
eBay and Yahoo and google all grew and
users bases at the same time at this
incredibly meteoric rate well that's so
much more developed now and think so
Skype actually grew like that and I'm
sure these guys you know they're the
same kind of thing but the it wasn't
like a long none of these had long
burnin cycles it was immediate demand
and so if you can start get it out there
and tap into whether that demand is
there for your product it becomes pretty
clear pretty fast and all of them were
really capital efficient except for its
on took the PayPal about a quarter
million Oh lots of five-dollar bounties
to users and about a hundred billion
dollars of fraud losses so PayPal went
through Wow quarter billion and mr. Issa
Mertzes money yeah it came out okay and
we still are and you know we had some
decisions to make no you know what did
we want to do but we didn't want the
service to suffer because we weren't
able to get the resources we needed and
we didn't want our community to suffer
so we we we had a good relationship with
Google and it was opportunity for us to
really accelerate development with what
they've had in place and you know at the
end of the day that's really what helped
us decide that this would be a good move
for us so yeah things things could
really get better instead of slowed down
for a while before we brought more
people on board and yeah so I think it's
it's worked out for us and and you know
in turn and the future our product is
gonna be better for it yeah I mean
whenever you choose not to do something
like that
there's obviously risk but I mean I
think if you're looking at the data that
we're looking at where I mean the user
base is doubling every five or six
months
you know we launched this product
newsfeed in September and engagement
pretty much doubled in one day
and just hasn't gone down since then
we're also looking at the fact that you
know I mean the user engagement on this
site is higher than it is on pretty much
any other site on the Internet
there's no reason why the user birth
won't continue to scale it's starting
internationally now as well right and we
haven't even localized into other
countries so that it's available in a
lot of other languages I mean right now
it's just growing so I mean the way
we're looking at it is that there's no
reason why in two years we won't have
hundreds of millions of users so I mean
and advertising revenues scaling really
well too
so I mean it's possible that it was a
bad decision but I don't think it is
takeoff can you elaborate on the time in
which your company you saw the traction
or the viral marketing working and those
things taking off and what do you think
the main reason was what is some
externality was a bunch of things coming
together they're all sudden things
started fitting and people started
inviting others can you elaborate on
that moment in time it's pretty a strong
brand around what you're doing says you
know it virally spreads people
understand you know a service that
you're providing and then you know for
the for the the growth to continue just
to be able to provide a consistent
service and an experience to the user so
you know with our architecture we were
able to provide that you know in terms
of continuing that growth and and when
when it actually happens I think we
didn't know what to expect we we thought
when we were serving a million videos a
day that you know that was unbelievable
you know how could we you know you grow
anymore and and every time we would plot
at a point where we would be in a few
months we were always exceeding that and
it's still kind of the case today so I
mean you just never know what to expect
and I think just to to get it out there
without really you know setting the bar
too low that you'll be successful in
creating a great product you know what
let me get one from up here yet
idea and like forecasts about where the
social sharing going and like what's
next and there was a new A&M people and
then Facebook and I'm like space so
what's the future what do you think is
gonna be the next big thing I know what
it is but I'm not gonna tell you exactly
that's really funny cuz when they told
me that was kind of the topic for this
panel and I said we're gonna have like
the brightest minds and that get up here
and tell a bunch of you guys what the
greatest I mean talk about you know
talking in front of the competition
there's just no way no actually one of
the things I find fascinating right now
is is the online collaboration Wikipedia
for me is an amazing site the my kids
use it as their core reference material
at school I mean it's not in
credibility's not an issue it's I mean
it's amazing site and the concept of
people not only submitting but people
working together to submit I'm on the
board of a company that is trying this
it's about to come out of stealth that's
trying to do the same kind of thing and
the concept that people can collaborate
online to make something better versus
you know just eBay was you can eBay was
for me up first an early web 2.0 company
because everyone was submitting their
goods for sale you know the submitting
videos submitting profiles but the
concept that they can then work together
to make it better is one that I find
really intriguing
that said all your sites have also grown
extremely quickly to have a huge this
huge base so my question is how worried
are you about our competitors coming in
and how sticky do you think is the
relationship with your customers well I
think what we build is a large library
video content and that's why we've you
know in turn created the largest
audience and what's really driving
people to put a piece of content online
is the reaction the amount of views that
would receive and we provide that for
them so it's very similar to the eBay
model where they have the most products
so in turn they have the most consumers
and you know when you're gonna sell a
product you want to get on eBay so it's
just the same thing for us the network
effect is valuable people definitely get
value out of the other people they're
actually probably no one would come to
the site if there was no one else there
right but I mean I think that it kind of
goes back to the first thing that I said
were these sites are about efficiency
people are trying to connect with you
know their friends and other people
around them and they're only going to do
this instead of other things that they
could do say the phone go meet someone
you know aim if it's more efficient than
that so the same applies for things that
would be potential competitors for us
and right now there are other sites that
are social networks or myspace is huge
and we're growing a lot into their user
base now so I mean the network effect
would suggest against that but I mean if
you're a more efficient entity for you
know that type of information flow then
I think that that's just like what you
need to focus on at eBay we had three
network effects company the only way you
can understand the Skype purchase you
know PayPal and eBay obviously put
together Skype is different is a belief
that network effects are determinate and
you know to date any site almost every
site that's developed in a real network
has maintained that network over time I
think the thing you worry about
particularly as companies as these
company starts aging I mean Bay is now
11 I think is are you going is the
disruptor going to get disrupted so you
actually become highly paranoid ever you
reading every new company is coming
around to say okay what is going to come
and provide a different
take on it no one's going to out auction
eBay and I don't think anyone's gonna
out you know out payment PayPal and for
what they do but you're widely paranoid
about what you know a new take on what
that could be and as a result groves
only the paranoid survive I think in
these cases you have to really be
looking over your shoulder it's not
they're not gonna come in the front door
they're gonna come into the window and
you won't you know you have to be
looking for what what impact pulls some
of these digital rights and copyright
issues have on YouTube going forward
yeah well I think you know we have to
work with the industry that create a
solution that works for everyone we're
not the only ones dealing with these
issues you know since it's video it's
it's more high profile but blogs deal
with the same things you have a copy a
purple from New York Times the post on
our blog that's a copyright infringement
I think what we're doing is building
ways to identify that when it happens
and then building new markets new ways
for the label studios and networks to
monetize that so as soon as we identify
a work so in the case with the music
labels were introducing audio
fingerprinting so when it identify as a
piece of music they'll be notified and
they'll have the opportunity to claim
that and earn revenue against it so it
benefits them and it also benefits our
user by giving them a free and legal way
to use something they couldn't in past
creating the concepts that fill everyday
client in their everyday consumer needs
and you know you oughta pool companies
YouTube you know have big consumer to me
but how important was Facebook what's
the first mover advantage I think it
helps but I mean there have definitely
been social networks before us and there
are other ones now that work and I
growing into their user base so I'm not
sure I mean early on sort of some of the
fiercest competition we had were like in
the first year when we were spreading to
all colleges before we started moving
into high schools and then post-grad
know that there were a lot of other
companies or it was mostly just students
at the time who were trying to build
other networks of colleges and like
groups of students would start off by
building a network of colleges that we
weren't added they'd try to guess which
ones we weren't gonna go to for a while
and I mean we just knocked all of them
off and I mean I don't I have to think
that it's because our product was just
more efficient I mean having a lot more
people is definitely useful but you have
to leverage that too right and I mean I
think that we rely a lot on you know
good product design in order to be able
to leverage the amount of information
that different people are putting into
the sites that people can get
information about or get good
information and get value out of that
you answer but yes I know I'll say from
a VC perspective I actually think first
mover is way over hyped in terms of it
you really need to back the best company
and the one that really meets the user
need and a lot of time first mover are
people who think of themselves as the
target market and build something before
the markets ready before the technology
is ready before the the critical mass
comes together the things that actually
can make it work it's really dangerous
to to try to come in and say you know we
see this - I'm gonna be bigger better
faster I'm gonna be 10% better you
cannot do you
can't venture back a 10% better company
right that doesn't work but very often
when you're still kind of in the
primordial soup stage of a market back
in the first one is the wrong is the
wrong decision because a lot of times
they're there the markets not ready
they're not ready or somebody's the
architecture is wrong and the bias is
wrong for what they're trying to
accomplish and I think you know a lot of
money gets lost and particularly a
market like this where everybody's
looking at the same things and you back
20 of them it's not a very successful
strategy or it hasn't been for most
companies that's eight years ago you
know 200 million dollars went after pet
food yeah well nothing I mean nothing
works right I mean that's what but if
you look at like the MMO space the
interesting you know we're an investment
MMO company and one things we have to
think about is by the time we ship a
title the platform will have increased
sufficiently that we can build features
that today we can't ship we're 24 to 36
months from now we know the gamers buy a
new PC every 18 months or less and we
can count on a different piece of
hardware then we can write to today and
so if you're writing to that you know so
so the markets not ready today you got
to make that investment for three years
planning on where that markets going to
be so I do think you can anticipate some
of this stuff unfortunately sometimes
you get it way wrong you know and then
and then your that's not a good thing
yeah but they do that by also being in
the content
and so far people have been willing to
allow single company business of
intermediary between proprietary systems
but I'm wondering if you think over time
there'll be some consumer pushback for
having single companies remember
Microsoft passport yeah I think the
users spoke up on that for the users and
they can remove it at any time we're not
we're not taking any rights we're not
trying to collect this and you know sell
DVDs or something down the road is it's
just uh we're just we just view
ourselves as a hosting service that
provides a service so to the extent that
we can provide the best service for
people we feel it's good for our users
drive time for one more feature said I
think it's a combination I think you
want an efficient interface you know you
don't need necessarily need the the
prettiest website to win in the space
you need to need something actually just
works and you know the technology on the
back end just goes hand-in-hand with
that first launch and we had absolutely
no features we had we didn't have the
ability did you add buddy remove buddy
anything and we just launched with a
clean simple interface and then ask
users what they wanted and we thought
the first feature that they went with
the add/remove buddy but we were wrong
and it ended up being jabber support
encrypted passwords and emoticons and we
would have never ever suspected that so
I think having a really clean interface
and then not trusting your own
intuitions about what features you think
they need but listening to the users is
absolutely key I think the two go hand
in hand you know the best some of the
best innovations we've had at eBay and
PayPal that weren't seamlessly
integrated in the user interface we're
DOA and I mean the key key there and we
call it getting it in the river I mean
there's raging river of traffic and if
you put it properly in a good feature
into that river of traffic
good user interface it was adopted you
know wholesale we buy it now became is
now I you know twenty billion dollar
business because it was seamlessly
integrated into that flow of traffic so
things like I think the two go
hand-in-hand and the both are necessary
to have it work you have a great feature
set if people can't find it and can't
use this not in the flow it doesn't
matter and vice versa right well we're
out of time with that I want to thank
our panelists and thank you